it's morning in the Kalahari and this
female cheetah has discovered that her
cubs are growing ever more independent
she calls for them but they've already
gone out exploring and they've
discovered a wounded gemsbok that may
have escaped from a lion its weak but
something tells them they're still out
of their league
they're intrigued but they don't know
what to do its horns could be lethal
it's too big even for their mother to
tackle eventually their curiosity
satisfied a he their mother and leave
the gemsbok to its fate young male
cheetahs like these often team up
together
where's female cheetahs live solitary
lives unless they have Cubs these two
are probably brothers and partners for
life they hunt go courting and today
they're exploring together the cheetah
cubs have gone out hunting without their
mother
and have come across a herd of gemsbok
and the hunt is on
they've caught a cap but they're about
to find out that like their own mother
the calf's mother is fierce when her
offspring are threatened
she's desperate to free her youngster
from the cheetahs strangling bite
the calves seems none the worse for its
adventure
and its mother turned to retention again
to the Cheetahs
the CAF had a lucky escape but the
cheetahs have been fortunate as well
gemsbok horns are deadly weapons the cow
could so easily have killed them when
the cheetah cubs are about 18 months old
they're old enough to leave their mother
and to seek their own fortunes once they
go she may never see them again